Assalamu alaikum.
[Silence]
later became between the two
and that that is a strategy of
teaching an entire society to
take up a particular a
particular fundamental of Islam
or or or principle of Islam.
And this pattern is seen
throughout the Quran and
Sunnah. Sometimes, when things
are made
obligatory or when things are
prohibited upon a society as a
whole in the Quran in the we
see this gradation that it will
start easy and then become
slightly more difficult,
slightly more difficult until
it reaches its final stage.
Sometimes, it will start easy
and then become more difficult
and then become less difficult
depending on the on the actual
issue at hand with fasting, it
began easy. A person would fast
by choice or feed for every day
that they miss a poor person.
Then, it became very difficult
because of a person fell asleep
after the Adan and woke up
during the night. They could
not eat anything or drink
anything until the following
day at and then it later
settled on what we know fasting
to be now which is
with the stamen of Allah and
eat and drink until you see the
break of dawn. This is where
the gradation of fasting and
its incremental obligation.
started as and where it
resulted at. We spoke about its
history. We spoke about some of
its benefits but we'd to
discuss today in more detail
the pillars of fasting and very
importantly the things that
break a person's fast and also
Things that do not break a
person's fast that are commonly
known amongst people or people
misunderstand to be something
that will break your fast. So,
Islam, Alam Aliya, Al Kauia,
Alah,
[Silence]
age a person who is sane, a
person who is a resident,
meaning they're not traveling,
a person who is of sound body,
meaning they are not ill and a
person who is, this is specific
to women, or females, that,
the, she not to be, that she be
in a state of purity, meaning
she is not, in a state
menstruation or he is not in a
state of postpartum, postpartum
bleeding. Now, we discuss some
of these rulings last week. We
will go over them and review
them very briefly. The first
thing is that a person be of
pubescent age which means that
a person be at the age of
puberty and
to
Thomas
[Silence]
have reached the age of
puberty. What do we mean by the
age of puberty? We're speaking
about when is a person
considered to be an adult? When
is a child no longer a child
and considered to be an adult
in Islamic law? Meaning that,
obligations are obligatory upon
them, prohibitions are written
against them, etcetera. At what
age? there's a lot of talk
about this amongst the scholars
of Filk and these things can
boil down. We can boil them
down to four things. Three of
them are you are unisex and a
fourth is specific to females.
The first thing is a wet dream
and that is the ability for a
male or a female to have sexual
a to the point of ejaculation
The second is that the pubic
hair becomes starts to grow.
When a person's pubic hair
around their private parts
begins to grow, this is
considered the age of puberty.
Third third of all, is if none
of these things happen, the
latest, the absolute latest a
person will become an adult is
the age of 15 years old and we
discuss this rather lengthily
last week. The fourth and final
thing which is specific to the
females is that they have their
menstrual cycle. Once a person
has any one of these or
multiple of these things occur,
they have reached the age of
puberty. Now, they are held
accountable and we mention what
is the age of puberty? What is
puberty? Ma Puberty is when the
brain and the mind of a person
goes through a change to where
they now are able to not only
recognize right from wrong but
also they are able to tie in
the consequences of right and
wrong. So, they understand this
is right and this is wrong but
they also are now able to look
into the future in a way and
see that consequences for
rights and consequences for
wrong and understand that
correlation and understand that
causation. This is what puberty
is. And when the brain goes
through this process of
puberty, it will secrete into
the body, hormones. And these
hormones will have an effect on
the body, have an effect on the
sound, have an effect on the
voice, etcetera. But it's most
prominent effects as we've
mentioned, are these four
things that we have just, that
we have just listed. So these
four things, they indicate that
the brain and the mind has gone
through that change to where a
person now not only understands
right and wrong or not only
knows right from wrong. I mean,
if you ask a child, is this
right? Is this wrong? The child
will respond. Yes, this is
right. No, this is wrong.
However, can the child
positively tie in his mind or
in her mind between this being
right and wrong and the
consequences of right and wrong
The answer is this is cemented
and becomes firmly established
in the mind at the age of
puberty and this is why a
person is not held accountable
until the age of puberty. And
so, once a person reaches this
age of puberty by one or all of
these things that we've
mentioned, the person now
becomes obliged by the laws of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. As
the prophet
has mentioned that
and his mention that the pen
until he regains his sanity,
the person who is, the person
who is a child until they reach
the age of puberty. So, this is
this is what is important with
regards to we can kind of
understand from this narration
The close correlation between a
person who's sleeping, a person
who is insane, a person who is
a child, a person who's
sleeping in your dreams, you
may do things in your dreams,
or you may say things while
you're dreaming, and you may
even know that these things are
wrong, but they still happen,
right? And you have very
strange consequences to these
things in your dreams, or while
you are sleeping. You may say
things, you may do things, and
you're sleeping, you're not
held accountable for these
things. wise a person who
is not saying a person who is
insane and there is a very
specific meaning to insanity in
Islamic law which will go over
inshallah and that is that a
person is insane legislatively
in jurisprudence of Islam that
this person cannot tie between
right and wrong cannot tie
between the consequence of
actions and the causes of their
actions and so forth. They're
not able to make that, make
that connection. Likewise, a
person who is young until they
reach the age of puberty. The
second thing we mentioned is Al
Amruthani, a a Psalm, who a
lady, Yakunu, Yakunu, Akilan
[Silence]
Has a book that he authored.
Some scholars debate whether
this book is is truly his
writing or not. But it has been
widely considered to be
authentically the book of
and
wrote a book called
the
[Silence]
between insanity and a lack of
intelligence is a person who is
insane may take the proper
steps to reach a particular
goal. However, the goal that
they are trying to reach is not
correct but a person of of low
intelligence, a person of of
idiocy is a person who whose
goal is correct but the way
that they go about achieving
that goal is is foolish.
There's a difference between
the two in Islamic law. When we
speak about insanity, we're not
speaking about what people
refer to as mental illness
today. That's a very broad
stroked meaning and and you
know, there's a reason that
mental illness has been so
expounded upon in our time
There is a mixture of truth and
falsehood in the psychiatry and
psychology elements of our
society, the psychologist, the
psychiatrist. Yes, this science
has evolved. It has taken on
many things and it's done a lot
of good for a lot of people
that needed some care. However,
it's become so broad that it's
turned into a money machine of
sorts. Meaning that it's almost
impossible. Almost impossible.
That you or I or any person
you've met is considered to be
mentally sound. If we go by the
criteria and the amount of
mental illnesses that are
mentioned, every single of us
is considered to be mentally
ill. The perfection of mental
health is not even existent.
It's non-existent. And this
shows us that it's gone further
than it should, right? So,
mental illness has expanded to
a point and bloated to a point
that it includes everyone of
us, all of us, right? And a
result of that is it's almost
impossible, not impossible but
almost impossible To go to
psychiatrist and not leave with
medicine. It's almost
impossible Not 90%, 95,
ninety-nine percent, I dare
say, of the time, if you go to
a psychiatrist, you will be
prescribed some kind of
medication. Which, which calls
into question, the veracity of
a lot of the claims of mental
illness, and the book of mental
illnesses that is referred to
and referenced. , it's
started out as having about 60
or 70 things and now it's
bloated to the hundreds of, of
mental illnesses that are
considered mental illness. So,
the the term mental illness has
become very expanded and that
is a lot of it has to do with
money. A lot of it has to do
with money. Because we have
major pharmaceutical
manufacturers. That insist and
higher researchers to research
and do tests and do you know do
do
do you know, different types of
experiments and so forth and
the meaning of mental illness
expands and expands and expands
and so there's a medicine for
almost every single person. So,
there's hardly a person that
you know that could, I've, I've
never met a person that would
not fit some kind of definition
of one of the many, many, many
types of mental illness that
they are. Now, this is not me
discrediting psychiatry. It's
not me editing psychology.
These are sciences that are
very important and crucial in
our in our time and to humanity
and a lot of these medicines
have in fact helped a lot of
people, a lot of people but
also, it has bloated far beyond
what it should be. To the point
that I've mentioned. So, when
we speak about sanity, Islamic
jurisprudence definition of
sanity is that a person is able
to hold a proper intention and
they are able to understand
that intention, right? So, they
are able to understand what
they're doing and understand
the consequences of what they
are doing. And they're able to
refrain from doing that which
is bad, harming others,
etcetera. This person is a
person who is considered
legislatively sane. But now has
different levels just like
insanity has different levels.
If a person is clinically
depressed, right? And I mean
really clinically depressed.
I'm not talking about they're
just down a little bit because
of their circumstances. I'm
talking about no matter how
good things are, no matter how
much they pray, no matter how
much this, they're clinically
depressed and there are
definitions for that, which and
certain criteria for that. If a
person is very seriously
clinically depressed. They may
do things. They may say things.
They may not do things. And
they know that these things are
wrong or they know that these
things need to be done.
However, will they be held
accountable for this? The
answer is, they will be held
accountable, but this illness
that they have, does mitigate
the accountability that they
will, will have, with regards
to this illness. So, if a
person, if a, a person becomes
clinically depressed, they know
that, this action is haram but
they do it, right? Will that
exonerate them that they're
clinically depressed? No,
they're not insane. They're
sane. They know that this is
wrong. They know that, you
know, but because of the
circumstances of their state of
mind, it may lessen their
accountability but it won't
exonerate them. Persons who
who's clinically depressed or a
person who has, you know, is is
been has been you know,
classified as having in other
kinds of other kinds of other
kinds of mental, mental
illnesses or issues You know,
such as such as for example,
schizophrenia, that's a very
good example. A person who has
schizophrenia, they start to
often times, they're the first,
the first, the first symptoms
of schizophrenia that come on
early and we don't really
understand schizophrenia very
well but usually it's a genetic
thing and schizophrenia usually
comes on either because of
schizophrenia or extreme or
drug use. Especially when a
person is very young. When
their brain is still developing
and their teenage years. And
they start to do things like
different drugs and experiments
with marijuana. Especially
marijuana's very dangerous
drug. Especially on a young
mind. That is still growing
it's on our in our society.
It's passed off it's
nothing. It's a very serious
thing. And it's very much has
long-term effects on the
development of the mind. The
person who does this is more
prone to schizophrenia. Which
will usually rear its head in
the person's 30s or 40s.
Sometimes earlier. Now a person
who's schizophrenic, the first
symptoms they will have usually
is that they will start to have
kind of scattered thoughts they
can't really keep keep one
train of thoughts and then
after that, they may start to
hear voices that are not their
own voice in their mind. They
might start to actually
literally hear things or
literally see things, okay?
Now, a person who has
schizophrenia, there there's
many different, there's many
different levels of
schizophrenia. A person may
just hear voices occasionally,
a person may just hear voices
but they still retain their
sanity in the sense that they
know this is wrong. The voices
are telling them to do
something wrong or that this is
right and the voices are
telling them not to do this
thing that is right. However,
schizophrenia may get so bad
that a person completely,
completely loses their sanity.
So, there's different levels.
It's not all the same. So, the
point I'm trying to make here
is that we need to
differentiate between clinical
mental illness and mental
illness or insanity in Islamic
law. Insanity in law is the
person is unable to make a
proper intention The person is
unable to understand what it is
that they are doing. This
person has fallen into a state
of insanity or their sanity has
been taken from them
momentarily because of extreme
anger or extreme sadness or
because of a fall. They fall in
their head. They get a
concussion. They start to
scramble things. They don't
know where they are They get
panic attacks. Something like
this. This is a type of
insanity. This person is is a
momentary insanity. This person
is not obliged to fast. Rather
when this person is in this
state, they they are not
obliged to fast. Let's say a
person has this happen to them
before the sun rises. Before
keyword, before the sun rises,
okay? They did not start their
fast yet. and then the next
day, they're fine. Let's say a
person falls, hits their head,
and they're not well for two or
three days, okay? Before the
sun rises. Are they obliged to
make up that fasting or not?
The answer is no. Because we
said this is the criteria for
fasting. Fasting was not
obligatory upon that person.
Okay? Contrary to a person who
fasts a portion of the day and
then and then this happens to
them. This person began
fasting. This person would have
to make up that fast. Etcetera.
The next thing that we want to
speak about is a person who is
a resident
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
Al Mu Call Allah
[Silence]
defined what that means. Number
three, that the person needs to
be a residence. Meaning that
they're not traveling. They're
not a traveler. Now, this issue
of a traveler and a resident.
It's an issue that's debated
highly amongst the scholars of
Filk of Ancient Time and recent
and latter. However
there if we look closely into
the verses of the Quran. We
look closely into the verses of
the prophet into the narrations
of the prophet we will come to
realize that there's really
only two categories of person,
people with regards to this
issue in the Quran and Sunnah.
The categories are a person is
either a resident or they are
travel those are the only two.
Some of the scholars have
mentioned, some of the have
mentioned. A third category and
that is a traveler, a a
resident, a traveler, or a
person who is a resident
traveler. So, they have three
categories. They say a person
who's a resident us. Now,
now, this is our neighborhood.
We live here and then we have a
traveler and then they have a
resident traveler. What is a
resident traveler? They say,
well, an example of these
three. Is for instance, a
person is here, they're going
to go for Umrah. When they're
here, there are residents. Once
the plane takes off, they are a
traveler Once they reached
their hotel, they are a
resident traveler And what are
the rulings of a resident
traveler? According to this
opinion, the rulings of a
resident are the rulings of the
resident traveler. Yet, this
this categorization is not very
strong. If we look at the
Quran, we look at the of the
prophet we see only two types
and that is a resident or a
traveler. Right? A resident or
a travel if a person is a
resident, they are in their
place of residence where they
reside and where they live. If
they are in a foreign place and
for a time which is not going
to make them to be considered a
resident such as they buy a
house or they live there or
what have you. Then this person
is a traveler. And this is the
opinion of Sheikh Al Islam
Rahim Allah and many others.
And also the opinion of Sheikh.
Sheikh
whose book we are reading now.
we will continue on this the
following class. Next week and
the week after, our class will
be will be postponed next week.
I will not be here in the week
after I will not be here.
the following week inshallah
after the eleventh of March, I
will be back inshallah.